this video is sponsored by the book
insights app blinkist use the link in
the description and you'll receive one
free week and 25 off an annual premium
membership
it was a normal sunny day in the German
Countryside the German nobleman Baron
Munchausen was out riding his horse on
his way to a town many miles away in
front of him was a long winding path
beside him was a large mire an expanse
of deep swamp and boggy ground
while the baron was looking up
peacefully enjoying the view with the
sun on his face suddenly his horse
jolted when the baron looked down to see
what was wrong he saw a badger running
in the opposite direction and his horse
running off the trail straight into the
mire with several heavy steps the horse
made it a good distance into the water
before its legs began to sink and become
stuck in the mud The Baron's legs wedged
in alongside the horse's body becoming
stuck as well frantically the baron
looked around he was miles from anyone
and many feet from the edge of the mire
there were no tree branches no rocks no
logs no Solid Ground to stand on
the horse flailed and squealed the baron
patted its Mane briefly calming it down
for several minutes the baron tried to
dislodge his legs with no luck then out
of complete desperation the baron
reached up and grabbed his own hair with
all his strength he pulled up
upwards he and the horse went
slowly the baron and the horse emerged
from the mud and returned safely to the
edge of the mire
[Music]
of course this is impossible and never
happened but the story of Baron
Munchausen serves as a metaphor and
reference for an incredibly significant
and unsettling philosophical thought
experiment known as the Munchausen
trilemma created by the German
philosopher Hans Albert in 1968 and
named after this story
according to the trilemma what we think
we know what we hold to be true is
impossible to ever prove
like the baron we are merely pulling
ourselves up by our own hair to escape
the mud and muck of uncertainty and
unknowingness with no Solid Ground to
stand on before delving further into the
Munchausen trilemma there's another
question or pairing of questions that is
useful to ask first
question one what do we know and how do
we know
in his book theory of knowledge American
philosopher Roderick Chisholm uses this
pairing of questions to reveal the
problem we face at the starting point of
knowledge which is known as the problem
of the Criterion for the avoidance of
confusion here we can consider something
knowledge if it is a Justified true
belief in order to arrive at this kind
of knowledge however we must be able to
answer at least one of these two
aforementioned questions what do we know
and how do we know answering one allows
us to answer the other and in answering
both we can Define separate and arrive
at Justified true beliefs or knowledge
in answering the first question where we
already know something is true we have a
particular case of knowledge that we can
determine a method or Criterion off of
to discern true versus false beliefs and
then use this method to determine other
true beliefs or in answering the second
question first where we know how we know
something is true we already have a
method or Criterion for determining true
versus false beliefs that we can use and
can continue to use
the problem and sort of paradox we
arrive at here though is we can only
find an answer to either question
through the other how can we know what
we know without a method or Criterion
for knowing first but how can we have a
method of knowing without knowing
anything first in other words we cannot
answer the first question without first
answering the second but we cannot
answer the second question without first
answering the first we are caught in a
loop
now here we find ourselves in the mire
the swamp of the Munchausen trilemma
trying to pull ourselves up by our hair
to defend what we know or think we know
question two
can we ever prove that anything is
fundamentally true
the Munchausen trilemma demonstrates
that there are only three ways to
justify something as true and none of
them sufficiently do so
the first way one attempts to justify a
proposition as true with another
proposition that requires the original
proposition to already be true this is
known as circular reasoning for example
someone might make the claim God exists
another person might then ask how do you
know the original person then says
because the Bible says so the other then
asks why should we believe the Bible the
original person says because it is the
Divine work of God
the problem here of course is that the
proposition used to justify the original
proposition as true presupposes the
original proposition as already being
true or simply restates the original
proposition in different terms this is
merely stating something as true it is
not justifying or proving anything
the second way one attempts to justify a
proposition as true with another
proposition that is not dependent on or
a restatement of the original
proposition but this new proposition
requires new further justification and
then the new justification does and then
the justification for that so on and so
forth into Infinity this is known as an
infinite regress for example someone
might ask why does the Earth exist
another person answers because gravity
pulled a swirling cloud of gas and dust
together to form a planet
the problem here however is where this
then goes in order to use this
proposition as a justification it also
needs to be justified and then the next
justification and the next and the next
add infinitum
why does Earth exist because a swirling
cloud of gas and dust Clump together why
did the gas and dust exist this
continual requirement for justification
would continue on in all directions into
infinity or into circular reasoning the
gas and dust came to exist because of
the Big Bang why did the Big Bang create
gas and dust because it caused matter to
exist in the universe to expand why did
matter come to exist in the universe
expand because the Big Bang occurred
the initial proposition cannot be
justified as true if there is never any
conclusive grounding or foundational
truth a stopping or starting point
present in a series of subsequent
propositions used to justify it
the last way one attempts to justify a
proposition is true by simply asserting
it as true without subjecting it to
further justification or proof
for example someone might say that car
is objectively red another person might
then ask how do you know because I can
see the red in this case a premise is
merely assumed to be true I.E one's
perception of red makes the redness of
the car true but of course assuming
something is true or claiming something
is true does not prove that anything is
obviously red may not exist outside the
human mind the human mind may be
deceiving the individual the individual
might simply be wrong with no way of
showing or proving that there is an
objectivity to what is being perceived
and or measured even with tools and
devices the human mind is still the
final stop for everything and there's no
way to prove a final belief without
assumption and Dogma
in the end we are left with
justification either by circular
reasoning by infinite regress or by
axiomatic statements or assumptions but
if justification by all of these is not
legitimate then justification is not
possible and if knowledge is Justified
true beliefs then knowledge is not
possible
this leads us to our final question and
philosophical problem
question three can there be any
philosophical progress
if absolute knowledge is impossible how
do we know if we are improving our
knowledge how do we know if we are
garnering any new knowledge what is the
point of philosophy if we can never
prove or know anything for sure in this
realm
The prominent Austrian philosopher
Ludwig Wittgenstein took this question
very seriously wickenstein believed that
philosophy in the traditional sense is
futile for him there is no structured
logical answer or solution to life and
there are very few if not no genuine
philosophical problems and any
individual who seeks them to answer them
conclusively are as he put it like flies
trapped in a transparent glass bottle
trying to escape by bashing against the
side with regard to his aim and
philosophy Wittgenstein said to show the
fly the way out of the fly bottle
[Music]
of course ironically wittenstein a
philosopher asked and answered these
questions doubting the purpose and value
of philosophy through philosophy
perhaps asking what is the point of
philosophy is the kind of question that
contains the answer in the mere Act of
asking it perhaps the purpose of
philosophy is less about progress
towards some end and more about a
process of inquiry and
self-understanding about examination and
exploration about expression and
connection with oneself with others with
the chaotic but beautiful nature of the
world
theoretical physicist Richard Feynman
said
I can live with doubt and uncertainty
and not knowing I think it is much more
interesting to live not knowing than to
have answers that might be wrong if we
will only allow that as we progress we
remain unsure we will leave
opportunities for Alternatives we will
not become enthusiastic for the fact the
knowledge the absolute truth of the day
but remain always uncertain
in order to make progress one must leave
the door to the unknown a jar
[Music]
sometimes philosophies like science and
math sometimes it is like music
sometimes you walk away with learning
something about the nature of things or
believing that you have sometimes you
walk away simply with the feeling that
you are a part of the nature of things
that you've been heard been understood
that someone out there who you'll likely
never know separated by potentially
immense distance and time is deeply
connected to you in thought and
Sensibility
that someone knows you well perhaps
philosophical progress is not merely
contingent on uncovering truths but
aiding in the harsh Barren reality that
there aren't any at least none that we
have access to
perhaps we are all trapped in the fly
bottle and no one's coming to let us out
but through things like science and math
music and art and philosophy we can make
the most of our time with each other in
here
while we are still in here
this video was sponsored by blinkist
so what'd you think of the cosmos
sapiens blank Kevin asked his friend
Eddie the two long time friends were out
getting lunch together super interesting
I never really thought about how much
culture and the time in history can
change how people see their place in the
universe and with the origins of
everything is like the book said science
is limited what will we think in the
future if you like that book you should
check out dark matter and the dinosaurs
by Lisa Randle it's about how scientists
understand and predict certain mass
extinction events Kevin replied Kevin
took out his phone and opened up the
blinkist app he went to the explore
section containing over 5 500
non-fiction books across 27 different
categories he searched dark matter and
the dinosaurs then he selected and
shared it using the new blinkus spaces
feature where they could share and
recommend titles to each other and their
other friends awesome yeah I'll
definitely check that one out how long
is the explainer for that one Kevin
looked down at his phone just over 15
minutes
both Eddie and Kevin took a bite of
their food I appreciate you sharing the
blankest connect account with me man
I've really been reading so much more
ever since Eddie continued of course man
didn't cost me anything it was free with
the premium account crazy how much one
habit can change your life right yeah
I'm gonna start sharing it with more
people honestly just tell them to click
the link in this video's description or
the QR code on the screen and they'll
receive a seven day free trial and 25
off link is premium what Eddie replied
confused we're an ad Eddie we're all ads
don't you get it that's how this works
Eddie looked at Kevin terrified
what happens after the ad ends
Eddie asked
[Music]
foreign